the office of the comptroller of the
currency
uh is now run by brian brooks who was
the former chief league officer at
coinbase as you know
uh yeah and within the first 60 days of
him being on the job
he issues the clarification that came
out um this past week
and essentially what he said is hey if
you are a bank
you should be able to custody uh the
value of
assets or valuable assets for your
customers that includes everything from
safety deposit boxes to virtual vaults
this kind of language they used
and that includes crypto currencies
being part of those valuable assets of
your of your clients and so
really issuing kind of a clarification
walk us through kind of your
understanding of like
what does this mean and what are the
ramifications it's a big deal
and it's a bigger deal than uh than most
folks in the crypto industry understand
uh and uh you know look the occ copied
wyoming
um his first pronouncement was
looking at a special type of payment
charter i knew that wasn't going to go
anywhere
because he would really have needed
congressional authorization for that he
can't just change an interpretation of
an existing law
uh and so i figured all right that's if
that's
if that's what we're up against you know
that's uh that's not gonna change
anything
but this announcement yesterday or two
days ago now absolutely changes
everything um because as of
two days ago national banks can custody
digital assets and it's just it is what
it is they don't need to go through
a special process unless this is a
material part of their business
the way the banking regulation works is
if it is a material part of your
business then you really have to go
through
a a procedure with your regulator where
they
review what your business plan is and
the impact on
the bank from a safety and soundness
perspective but if it's one of the
behemoths
literally they can be in the business
tomorrow because it's not going to be
material it's not it's not going to have
a big
impact on the bank from a safety and
soundness perspective so
um yeah we uh we've got ears to the
ground we've got a lot of people
multiple people who are inside the
circle uh i did not know this was coming
most people didn't they kept it a
a big secret but it's here and it's it's
a much bigger deal than folks realize
um in part because of some pieces that
that haven't fallen into place yet
uh but uh you know um every u.s bank
is now able to custody crypto and when i
say every
some are probably thinking wait a minute
what about the state banks
only a relatively small fraction of the
number of banks in this country are
regulated by the occ
or the occ regulates national banks and
then there are 50 state regulators that
regulate state banks
at the end of the day they're not
different and there's maybe a perception
that a national bank has a
has a an advantage just because it's
national but here's
here's the difference state banks have
the exact
same master account at the federal
reserve that a national bank has they
can do the same things
and that state member banks by law can
do everything that a national bank can
do
so this is why i say every bank in the
country now
can uh can can custody digital assets as
a result of that interpretive letter
uh the interesting question is who put
that interpretive letter in
that would have had to have been one of
the national banks and uh
my first reaction was i was assuming it
was goldman sachs goldman sachs is a
state bank they're not a national bank
so
i went uh i went i poured through the
list of national banks and by the way
we've gotten a couple calls from
national banks
uh as well because everybody has just
you know
the not everybody realizes yet how
meaningful this is because i've seen
some uh some comments from
from some of the native crypto companies
uh that indicate to me they don't
understand what really happened yet
uh but they will they'll figure it out
um the entire landscape in the u.s just
shifted
and uh now you need a bank license in
order to be competitive that that's
that's the bottom line
i'll also point to fidelity digital put
out a tweet yesterday that indicates
they get what's going on
uh and i'll paraphrase it they said you
know congratulations to the national
banks for
for coming into this industry uh we'd be
happy to be your sub custodian
that tells you that tells you what they
know they they know what's going on
and uh for fidelity to be a sub
custodian to
a national bank it's one of the big ones
so there's kind of two components here
right so a national bank
basically asked and said can you clarify
for us what their current rules are
uh the occ has clarified and said yes
you may custody
uh cryptocurrency there's the
implications on the legacy
uh kind of financial organizations and
there's an impact on the crypto
companies
let's start with the crypto companies
because i think that's kind of more cut
and dry
you previously said that now it's going
to require a bank license for people to
be competitive on the custody side
uh kind of elaborate on that a little
bit and explain it well custody and
prime brokerage uh and maybe even
exchange
um you know again it's so sort of funny
i figured out
a couple years ago when i was in wyoming
working you know spitballing on what
what should a state do to grab a
competitive advantage
we figured out that you needed to have a
bank license in order to have a
competitive
advantage here um and and and the basic
simple observation is crypto settles
very quickly
dollars settle very slowly it's not it's
not complicated
uh and if you're trying to do crypto to
fiat um
you've got some settlement problems
which which which injects
something called hair shot risk which is
airshot was a big german bank
that um that failed in the financial in
the foreign exchange market
and triggered a cascade of of losses
among a lot of
a lot of banks um and really what it is
is basically you just got settlement
risk if you don't have
it's it's like you know trading a
baseball card right both
both people hold on to the baseball card
and then they let go at the same time
that's uh that's uh uh you know you're
again kids kids tend to have the uh the
better understanding
of the way the world should work right
and the adults screwed it up
and set up these um very different
settlement cycles
for uh for for for for dollars
um and then there are a lot of wrinkles
inside of it too
uh fed wires can be reversed most folks
don't know that
you don't have settlement finality with
fed wire and then ach is a very big deal
um because you ach transactions for
consumers
they can reverse an ach transaction for
60 days beyond the settlement beyond the
statement period
and if you're at the beginning of your
statement cycle that means
your ach transaction isn't actually
settled for 90 days so this is the
reason why the crypto companies
have uh you know if you put if you if
you ach
uh a dollar payment into one of the
crypto exchanges
they typically don't give you access to
it right away they they want to know if
you're going to try to take it back
um and there's a lot of ach fraud you
know we
i think most folks are aware of the
chargeback risk and credit cards but
there's chargeback risk in dollar
payments too
so those are a lot of the real world
problems and when we started working on
some of our products we
we spent a lot of time talking to
institutional traders
but also just users of of the payment
system you know keep in mind i came from
the corporate world
corporate treasury world um working with
corporate treasurers when i was on wall
street
and uh they live this pain every day
um there's a there are a lot of problems
with the fact that the us dollar
payments are delayed so
i i figured out pretty early on and and
i haven't even talked about the
securities piece
you know what does it take to be a
qualified custodian a trust company
doesn't cut it
uh because of the way the laws are
written you've got to be a bank and a
bank
in one part of the custody rule says you
you can be a trust company
but in a part of the custody rule that
really matters it says you've got
it does not include a trust company and
the definition of bank means
takes deposits and makes loans um so
you um or you've got to be a a state
chartered bank
which is what avanti is um but you've
got to you've got to fit into those
categories in order to be a true
qualified custodian
and um and trust companies uh unless
they do fiduciary business which the
there's only one trust company in that
the custody's crypto that i know of
that does fiduciary business fiduciary
business means you're exercising
discretion over company assets you're
taking
fiduciary responsibility for those
assets that is not what trip
what typical cryptocustody is so this is
a long convoluted answer
to say the trust company licenses are
now obsolete
if a bank can custody crypto
particularly if it's one of the big guys
uh all the native crypto companies now
need to get bank licenses and you know
it's funny i was screaming this from the
mountaintop long before i started avanti
get a bank license right president trump
told
libra get a bank license it's not like
folks weren't warned um get a bank
license well it's here now everybody's
gonna have to get a bank license and
it takes nine to twelve months to get a
bank license i i don't like the fact
that it does but it does it's an
unbelievably difficult process which is
why
probably a lot of folks looked at it in
wyoming and didn't get it started
uh and i'm very glad i did because you
know now i think avanti's in the pole
position we're in a really interesting
position
relative to the shift that just occurred
in the industry